so i feel like social media has made it  harder for relationships to work because  you're as you're as a guy you're seeing  all these beautiful girls on your  timeline  constantly you're gonna be tempted  you're like oh there's more beautiful  girls out there you're seeing all these  girls so you're so it's like it's  tempting you and you're seeing that  every day constantly constantly you're  like oh  oh yeah i think it works both ways as  well though because as a guy  like back in the day you were just  obviously before social media if you  were just competing with the guys that  went to your school or the guys in your  area and now you're competing with  people from america that have yachts  people who have  planes  like and you're just here like  i'm making off but like oh i ain't got  no your